reject
all right
good morning
i should have slides in a second hold on
there we go
good morning berlin
show of hands who feels that they slept
really well last night
all right that's great who feels that
like they're a little bit tired this
morning and they could have maybe gotten
a better night's sleep
i certainly feel that i flew a long way
to be here
uh i'm nick
i'm a software engineer and i've always
had trouble sleeping
and
i got interested in sleep very seriously
when i went off to university and i
started taking it seriously and i've
spent the last seven years tinkering
with my sleep cycle with my circadian
rhythm and today i'm using javascript to
power an artificial environment that
helps me get a better night's sleep and
i'd like to tell you about it
why would you want to hack your sleep
like why would you go down this road of
starting to play with your circadian
rhythm
i think if you're tired in the morning
you wake up and you feel like it's hard
to get up and get going in the day
that's a good reason or maybe if when
you go to bed at night you've got like
your mind racing and you've got great
ideas and you're just not ready for bed
at the right time
if you go to work and like 2 p.m this is
you and your head is like crashing into
your laptop
that'd be a good reason to hack sleep
and also kind of interestingly
certain kinds of depression are linked
with sleep and certain kinds of
depression can be treated very well by
hacking your sleep i think that's really
cool i'll have more to tell you about
that
maybe
you wake up every morning and you kind
of feel like this
i hope none of you are feeling like that
right now or maybe in the night you
don't feel like this and hopefully
that's not you at work
poor little dog
my house is a smart environment it's a
smart home which means that it thinks
and does things but not that it's
brilliant
um
and if you were to hang around in my
house for a long time here's some
interesting things you would notice
first you would notice there are no
light switches or if there are light
switches they've they've got a little
post-it tape to them that says no don't
touch
and
this is because i haven't touched light
switches in many months and
every light in the house is addressable
every light in in my home you can say to
that light i'd like you to be this color
this intensity and it can set itself to
any of millions of colors and then
different brightnesses as well
and all that means that interestingly
the lights turn themselves on and off
throughout the day and this works with
my natural rhythms to make sure i'm
getting a good night's sleep or i'm
awake at the right time
so this is really cool it's geeky it's
fun to hack on it's powered by
javascript and it's had a big impact on
my my sleep and my quality of life so
i'd like to tell you what it's like like
a day in my life and walk through what
that is and how that works
i live here in pacifica california which
is a pretty bright environment and it's
uh it's very near san francisco although
just outside right by the ocean
um
and a day in my life looks something
like this
i wake up in the morning i get ready for
my day and i get ready to leave and then
i go off to work
and then in the evening i come home and
the sun naturally sets and then i go to
bed
but in that cycle the house is doing
many things so in the morning about 60
minutes before i wake up my living room
lights turn on and they come up and they
are bright white which is designed to
help me feel awake and the kitchen
lights turn on and that looks something
like this
early in the morning the living room
lights come on as bright white and like
i said the kitchen lights come on as
bright white to make sure that like when
i go out to have a bowl of cereal that
i'm awake and ready for my day
then the house does something really
cool about 30 minutes before i get up it
runs code to simulate a sunrise
so in the bedroom there's this big rig
of lights and they look like this some
lights are pointing up some lights are
pointing down to make sure that there's
an even distribution of light throughout
the room
and the lights dim up on an s curve and
this mimics what the sun naturally does
the sun begins to rise uh slowly and
then accelerates over time uh this is in
terms of brightness and then the starts
to level off and it doesn't get bright
as quickly and so the lights in my
bedroom mimic this same pattern
they come up with a very specific color
temperature
light colors are measured in kelvin
and
as you see here like a thousand kelvin
is very warm and very yellowish and like
10 000 kelvin is very cool so the lights
come up sort of in the middle but edging
more towards the cool blue because this
has a big impact on how we feel and
what's happening in our body first thing
in the morning
then it's time to go and all the lights
in the house they tell me it's time to
go they just turn off so this is really
helpful because i don't have to like
look at my watch and wonder is it time
to go for my day and it's really cool
then i go off to work at a really cool
fashion and tech company called modcloth
i don't think they're very big in
germany i know they're not very big in
germany but we're very cool and you
should check us out
and then this same process sort of
repeats and goes backwards when i get
home so about 60 minutes before bedtime
the house begins to turn off different
lights in the house to encourage me
towards
my bedroom so the kitchen lights go off
the office lights
dim down which is a really good signal
like time to stop hacking
time to get ready for bed and then
more lights go off until at bedtime the
whole house goes off signaling like time
to go to bed and then the lights just on
the outside of the house turn on to make
sure the house is secure
so that same process repeats
all of this runs on a little x86
computer a little intel knock and all
the codes written in javascript and i'll
tell you more about some of the specific
code that runs the house a little bit
later on
this system is the result of a lot of
research it hasn't always looked like i
just walked you through today and it
hasn't always taken up my whole house
i want to tell you how my house has
evolved in terms of hardware and
software and how i came to control all
of it in javascript and why i think
javascript is the right choice for this
kind of control
at the end of the talk i'll give you
some ideas on how if you're interested
you can start hacking your sleep so that
you don't raise your hand during the
part when i say like are you a little
bit sleepy
before we go on a couple of disclaimers
i'm not a doctor i'm going to summarize
some medical research but i want to make
it clear that i have no advanced
training in medicine and so anything i
say you should do your own research and
consult your own doctor i'm not giving
you medical advice
i'm not a scientist and so i believe
i've interpreted everything i've read
correctly but if i haven't and you know
it i'd love to know about that
i'm not a lawyer and so what i have to
say is everything i present in this talk
is for entertainment purposes only
i've already invited you into my house a
little bit i should make it clear i'm
also not an interior designer
any critiques you have of my interior
design are probably well deserved
i am an engineer though which means that
i'm willing to dive into things i'm
willing to tinker with things and i
really want to understand things at a
deep level
i'm not saying that our bodies are
machines because we're not our bodies
are very complicated we respond to
stress in the environment in ways that
are more complicated than any machine
ever could but what i am saying is our
bodies are a lot like a machine and if
you understand the inputs you can change
the outputs
before we go on i think it's helpful to
understand circadian rhythm and what it
is and how it works and so there's this
great youtube channel called scishow and
i have the permission of hank green to
show his video about circadian rhythm so
i just have a short clip here
which may have audio
all right
audio
okay
that's all right uh we don't have audio
here um
so what this guy is saying i will
summarize for you uh so our body has
this natural internal clock called a
circadian rhythm and your circadian
rhythm is flu influenced by all kinds of
things like light and stress and sleep
and your circadian rhythm controls
all sorts of things that are going on in
your body but most importantly it
controls when you're awake and when
you're asleep um how tired you are your
desire for food and
um
and and things like that there's two
important chemicals that are involved
with regulating your circadian rhythm
there's melatonin which spikes in the
evening and
makes you feel sleepy and ready for bed
and then there's cortisol which spikes
in the morning and makes you feel alert
and awake and ready to take on the day
these chemicals are influenced by a lot
of things but most importantly for me
light
so
i haven't always lived in california i
grew up in upstate new york and i think
geography has a big impact on who you
are the kind of weather and climate you
grow up in has a big impact on how you
see the world and what's normal to you
for quick reference upstate new york is
a long way from new york city it's a 535
kilometers or as we would say about an
eight-hour drive
and it looks like it looks like this so
this is from my university the year is
2006 and this is what my world looks
like and i'm pretty unhappy
i'm having trouble going to classes i'm
having trouble getting up in the morning
and it's just really hard for me to
to do the things i need to do so i went
to a doctor to a professional and he
said ah this sounds like seasonal
affective disorder which is also called
the winter blues
and
it's a kind of depression that comes on
as the days get darker
and then recedes as the days get lighter
so i started to do my own research about
this and started to think about it
but before i could really do anything
about it summer arrives and this is
summer in upstate new york it's
beautiful it's the kind of thing people
write poetry about
people go boating and it's bright and
it's light and so i was just not
affected during the summer so my
research stopped
fall returns and again i'm having
trouble sleeping and i'm starting to do
research and i came across this
paper that had a big impact on how i
started to think about sleep and it's
titled circadian rhythm phase
advancement with dawn simulation for
treatment of winter depression
and
i will read you
one quote from the abstract
the authors conclude that bright light
and dawn treatment simulations both
produced average phase advancements
advancements of about 30 minutes while
other tested effects had minimal effects
the authors conclude that very dim
incremental levels of light at the end
of the night with a dominant red
component
through eyelid filtering facilitates
circadian rhythm phase advancement
possibly in conjunction with room light
after awakening so that's pretty dense
but what the authors are saying is that
light dimming up slowly in the morning
begins to wake up your circadian rhythm
and begins to shift you back into a
normal rhythm and routine and what they
found is that this can be as effective
as bright light therapy
for treating seasonal affective disorder
so i read all of this and i thought as
an engineering student i can do this
so i built this
which doesn't look like much
but
it consists of two lights and a dimmer
plug hidden under the bed
and that box labeled control was my
first step in building an artificial
sunrise and programming this thing was
awful it was like uh like early gaming
systems like you would hold down buttons
with the right combination for the right
amount of time and that's how you would
program the system
it was not very advanced but it did
start to get me to think about sleep
and so i used it for about a year and
then summer returns and it's beautiful
and i didn't really need the system
anymore and i concluded that this was a
cool geeky project
and it was a nicer way to wake up in the
morning and i felt a little bit better
so i used that for about a year and fall
returns of course in university you're
always moving new apartments new people
so when fall returned i had a new place
and i had taken it all apart and i
started thinking about the amount of
light i got throughout the day so this
is like a typical noonday scene in
upstate new york during the fall
as you can see it's not very bright now
i've only spent a little bit of time in
germany but it seems like the climate
here is perhaps very similar
so i started to think about getting more
light and i built a new system
as you see the system needed a lot more
hardware which was great
what you see here is there's two lights
by the bed that dimmed up very slowly
and then two lights pointing down they
could also dim up very slowly and that
like the previous system would work over
about 30 minutes and then after that
dimmed up very slowly awakening me
nicely
chunk
i'd get this huge dose of light um
so these bright lights were put together
to do bright light therapy and make sure
i was being exposed to enough light
this whole thing got me thinking about
sunrise and sunset and the effect of
light that light has on us throughout
the day
with all this more hardware which was
great
i also needed more software to control
it so the system moved from something
that was programmed kind of like an
early game system to being a full-on
laptop which was stuffed away in a
closet
and i wish i had code from this time but
it was all visual basic
we can debate about whether that's real
programming or not
but it was a lot more complicated i had
now had to talk to a serial port and i
was bit shifting out across it
i had to do funny things like make sure
lights still existed on the network i
was talking to and sometimes lights
would just cease to be on the network
and all of this made it really hard to
talk about high-level abstractions i
couldn't talk about like this is the
state i want the world to be in at this
time i had to think very low level about
serial ports and lights and rf noise and
if it's lightning and raining and just
all these kind of complications which
were fun to solve but not really what i
was interested in as i was hacking my
sleep
so i used this for about a year it had a
really great impact i felt happier i was
more likely to go to class
and things felt a lot better in my life
after i built this system
i was really tired i just finished
university
and it was
time for me to get my first job
i moved across the country to california
and
i needed to build a new system to get me
into a regular routine because now it
wasn't like university anymore where i
had three or four hours of classes and
the rest of my time was my own instead
now i needed to get up every day put on
a shirt go to work and be awake and do
good work every day
so i built another system
this system i wanted to have much higher
uh girlfriend approval factor
so you'll note that this system has way
less wires uh and it looks way less
intimidating
i thought that bright light therapy
might still be a part of my life i
wasn't sure how much exposure to light i
was going to get and i wasn't sure how
much i was going to need so i set the
system up to do that but as it turns out
that wasn't really necessary because i
was getting enough light throughout the
day
the control also evolved a lot as well
the control system moved from visual
basic to lua and it was on this little
green box called avera
um and the code to actually run the
sunrise looked like this
and i i can tell it's a little hard to
see what's going on up there but i think
the the key takeaway was uh visual basic
the code was pages and pages and pages
and the code to run the sunrise here is
about 20 lines so it's getting better it
was possible for me to talk about more
high level abstractions
and
it was possible for me to think more
about the system holistically you'll see
i'm still dealing with the upnp spec
here which is no fun for anyone that's
ever dealt with that it's a lovely soap
api
but this was a big step forward in terms
of control
more sunlight i was less focused on the
seasonal affective disorder and more
focused on just sleep in general and
feeling awake and alert
and so
i started to hack my sleep from both
ends
now when i was looking at what i wanted
to do next i used this great program
called flux flux is a program for your
laptop which after sunset color shifts
your screen so that you're no longer
being exposed to blue light as much and
it makes sure you're being exposed to
more yellowish red lights and i've been
using this for some time a friend had
recommended it to me and said like this
really helps with my sleep you might be
interested so i'd installed it
and i'd been using it and i think it
kind of had helped my sleep
but i wondered like is this real science
or is this like pseudoscience like uh we
promised this is gonna work
so i went to their website and i started
looking into their research and these
guys are really really serious about
research they had like 400 journal
articles linked about the effects of
different kind of light on your
circadian rhythm
and
lots of great articles but i think i
think that this article
was very clear and very easy to
understand
so the new york times published this and
the conclusions that they publish what
they come to is the kind of light that
hits your eye throughout the day has a
big impact on what's going on in your
body and that orangish yellow light
helps to release melatonin in our body
and that bright white and blue light
helps to stop melatonin from being
produced and helps to produce cortisol
now this is great news if you're out in
nature and the sun is naturally rising
and that's your environment and it's
kind of bad news if you're stuck inside
all day and
you're looking at lights that are coming
down on you
the other bad news is our laptops tend
to put out really bluish white light and
so if you're working late into the night
you're actually stopping your body from
producing the chemicals that make you
sleepy and feel ready for bad
so i thought like okay this is really
cool because at the same time phillips
came out with this new kind of bulb
called the hue
and the hue lets you produce millions of
colors i was telling you about what it
does in my house earlier
and i thought okay great if it's bad to
be exposed to blue light at night i can
do things
to make sure that i'm not being exposed
to that harsher blue light and instead
i'm being exposed to more yellowish red
and that in the morning i can be exposed
to things that make me feel awake
now the hue has a great uh control api
it's all over http
and i started looking at how i can
control these bulbs and make them do
what i want and not just work with the
little iphone app that it ships with
so i had to build out a lot more
advanced system and this is when i came
to javascript and i want to tell you
about three parts of the system that i'm
using today to control my house
i want to tell you about the clock
and the the config
translation and then how the bulbs
themselves are actually controlled
so the key object in my system is a
clock
and the clock translates the like
ticking of a clock to javascript events
that i can bind onto so i can for
example register that the natural sun
sets at 6 30 like this
and then in the system at 6 29
onto a global event bus gets fired this
event one minute before sunset
and then at 6 30 the event gets fired at
sunset
and then at 6 31 one minute after sunset
the clock has a really small api
um
and this is something i love about
javascript is that you have these small
libraries that are really focused on one
thing and so you can really understand
the api that you're working with and
take full advantage of it
the clock gets cleared at midnight and
all events get cleared out so that the
next day they need to be repopulated
so remember before i had this slide up
with my getting ready for sleep schedule
what we're actually looking at here is a
markdown file and this markdown file
gets read and parsed by the system
and gets converted to this javascript
file
so before i was showing you the clock
and i was saying the clock fires events
like one minute before sunset well here
you see that markdown file got
translated so 60 minutes before bedtime
became an event that the system's
actually looking for
and then the home
sets the lights to the right temperature
so this is really great because my
girlfriend doesn't write javascript she
but she does understand how to read a
markdown file and so this is a really
great place for us to be able to
communicate about what the house is
going to do and make sure that
we both understand and then it gets
translated to code that actually gets
run here all of this gets read and
parsed with jyson which is the same tool
that coffeescript uses
the last thing i want to tell you about
is the
hue api
now i didn't write this this is written
by a guy called peter murray and this is
the best control library for the hue
i've tried them all i've tried them in
java and ruby and javascript and this
one is the most fun to work with and i
think the most productive
i love that the library is built with
one small purpose before i started
writing this system in javascript i
toyed with writing it in ruby
and
i had found that i was building this big
framework for controlling my house and i
was never controlling my house i was
never hacking my sleep because i was so
focused on building this framework when
i started writing in javascript i found
right away like ah i'm writing the code
to control my house and to sleep better
and that felt great
so here's the smallest amount of code
you can do to control the hue and i want
to highlight one line in particular
here we see light state now this is the
problem i'd had with all of the other
systems i've been programming in in
visual basic it was talking with serial
parts and lua it was talking to upnp but
finally here in javascript i'm just
saying here is the state of the world
that i want i want the light to be on i
want it to be white and i wanted to have
this warmth and this intensity and this
is great this does exactly what you
think it would do it turns the light on
and it it's really great to work with
another great thing is i no longer have
to worry about nodes disappearing from
the network that's all handled by the
hue api
you can do so many cool things with this
you can turn the lights on and off you
can alert them
you can set them to different colors and
then you can do really cool effects
like i said all of this runs on a little
computer that draws almost no energy the
intel knock platform is really cool it's
really low energy and you can leave it
on day and night and not feel too guilty
about it
so this is all pretty cool if you're
interested in hacking your sleep here's
some advice that i have
the easiest thing you can do
it costs no money is to try flocks you
can get flux at justgetflux.com
like i said this color shifts your
computer screen so that at night you're
not being exposed to so much blue light
the only downside i can come up for this
pro with this program is it's not
written in javascript
the next thing to try is setting an
alarm for bedtime
now my lights
turn off at different times which has
really helped me get to bed at a
reasonable time
what i've found though is that really
just having that trigger like anything
happening it helps that the lights are
the right color but anything happening
to get me closer to bed is a big deal we
really are creatures of habit and so i
know we're all used to setting alarms in
the morning but setting an alarm in the
evening
can be really effective at helping you
get a great night's sleep
cut down on the amount of blue light
that you get
you see on the left
you can do really cool things with the
hue bulbs
now this isn't easy um i know the siren
call of my my ipad and my
phone at night and
wanting to check my email it's really
hard to get away from our devices but
the more you can put your device away
especially after the sun sets and the
less blue light you can get the more
melatonin your body produces and the
more ready for bed you'll feel and
consequently the more awake you'll feel
the next day
and finally if the if the hue stuff is
interesting to you
um it's so cool these bulbs are
available in the us and the eu
and they're great fun to hack around
with
my system has made a big difference for
me it's helped with my sleep it's helped
with my happiness
and it's really been a big part of my
life like i said i've been doing this
for about seven years and i'm nowhere
near dawn right now i'm thinking about
daylight savings time so daylight
savings time normally you're waking up
at one time every morning and then
suddenly you've got to fall behind and
like suddenly you're waking up an hour
difference and that's really hard on
your system so the next thing i'm
looking at is gradually moving the time
i wake by three or four minutes every
day leading up to daylight savings time
i think that's going to have a big
impact on my sleep
i'd love to hear if this inspires you to
do something cool or if you're doing
something cool around this already
and let me know i'm nick ceramis on
twitter thank you very much
reject